[Music]
hey how you doing
hey how you doing
hey how you doing i'm good
you're new here right yes i worked the
night shift
my name is bart well it's very nice
meeting you bart
what it's nice to meet you i'm sorry i
have to practice
what to say hey how you doing i watch
people
and i imitate you watch people
well i study them yeah well i guess you
have a lot of people to watch
at the hotel yes i do
[Music]
we have a dead woman here and i think
bart knows something about that
we find your fingerprints all over the
room this is a fragile boy and you need
to understand that
look i know you got issues
but you're hiding something that's what
i really believe bart
i drove home and i watched i watched tv
you're a very smart guy and yet what
you're saying to me doesn't make sense
you know you can tell me anything honey
[Music]
he has kind of an odd way about it
but you know that doesn't mean you
didn't eat that does it
oh god oh god oh god it's okay it's okay
it's okay it's okay
bart what did you do what did you do
what did you do bart oh my god
what did you do
[Music]
you